thank you
this is AVM
[Music]
since we first learned to use magic
we've waged War over who would control
it
now only lucium remains to resist the
Tyrant of rashan sandrak will eventually
be able to block our access to Magic
than the ever war is over over as in he
takes over lucium as in he takes over
everything
[Music]
there's a name for what you are a Magnus
I want to be an immortal I want to fight
this war as one of you one of the elite
I believe in you she definitely thinks
you're going to die that's why her face
looks like that
[Music]
foreign
prevent it from killing you
a child whose new powers could make them
a threat to the kingdom I protect
Choice was to either kill you
or turn you into a weapon against rashan
option A was to kill me
[Music]